يلا الينا الان من القدس شلون الكاتب
والمحلله السياسي سجلومه كيف قرات اسرائيل
نشر هذا الفيديو المصور اليوم خاصه وانه
تزامن مع تبادل مناصب رئاسه الاركان في
اسرائيل
لم تعقب على هذا الفيديو
وايضا يتم في هذه الساعات تشخيص والتاكد
من صحه هذا الفيديو هل هو الذي
ظهر في هذا همم شريط
والعائله عائله مانجو نفسها تشك في ذلك
وربما لسبب قضيه تسع سنوات على عدم رؤيته
ولذلك ربما هناك همم في الموضوع ولكن من
حيث المبدا اسرائيل
من ديوان رئاسه الحكومه وصف هذا شريط
بالخدعه وقال بانه سيؤخر صفق التبادل
الاسرى هناك موقف رسمي
هذا هو بمجرد البيان التنقيبي الاولي ولكن
ليس البيان الرسمي المفصل الذي قد يصدر قد
يصدر في عقاب التاكد من صحه الفيديو وفي
هذه الساعات كما ذكرت يتم تحليل هذا
الفيديو للتاكد لان هذا هو مانشستر شخصيه
والمعرفه والاستعانه بمصادر اخرى للتاكد
منا من هدف هذه الرساله خاصه وان حماس لما
اا تعلن عن الثمن الذي تريده مقابل نشر
هذا الفيديو خلافا للسابق ولكن تعريف هذا
الموضوع يجب ان نقول بصراحه بان هناك
اختلاف في وجهات النظر الاساسيه ففي حينما
تعتبر ان جميع الاربعه هم جنود ربما على
قيد الحياه ولم تفصح عن عن صحه هذا
الموضوع اسرائيل تعتبر اسرائيل الرسميه
والشعبيه تعتبروا ان المدنيين الاثنين
ابانجو وايضا المواطن البدوي هم مواطنين
عاديين وانهما
همم مريضين نفسيا وان الجنديين ليس على
قيد الحياه بل هما بمثابه
وشهداء لجيش الدفاع ولذلك
تمسك حماس بالموضوع هو منافي لل- اا
القيم الاسلاميه
هذا الشريط المصوره وان كان مدنيين كما
تقول اسرائيل الى اي مدينه يمكن لنشر هذا
الفيديو الان ان يضع ملف الاسره كاولويه
يتعين على الحكومه الحاليه التعامل معها
وان كان الاسرى مدنيين
ليس اولويه ولكن ممكن اقول لكل امانه وصدق
بان هذا الموضوع فرض نفسه بالقوه على جدول
اعمال الحكومه على الراي العام الاسرائيلي
وعلى الراي العام الفلسطيني بصوره خاصه
وان الحكومه الاسرائيليه والمجلس الوزاني
المصغر يجب ان يتدخل في الامر لمناقشه
الموضوع بعد طبعا التاكد من صحه الفيديو
والحصول على المعلومات الاخرى من قبل
الوسطاء المختلفين وعلى راسهم الوسيط
المصري
وتحريك العمليه ولكن هناك يجب ان نقول ان
عبره جميع الحكومات الاسرائيليه المختلفه
السنوات الاخيره منذ صفقه شليته الاخيره
همم 12 سنه ممكن نقول بان هناك موقف
اسرائيلي او شبه موقف اسرائيل جامع الرفض
اي معيار ليه ان يكون
مفقودين والاسرى بالمعيار الذي تمت فيه
صفقه الشريط والذي بموجبه اعادت اسرائيل
او افرجت عن 1027 شخصا مقابل اسير حي اا
واحد اعتقد ان هذا هو ايضا توصيل
مسؤوله نعم
القدس اكمل
ولكن
اليوم ما تبدل الحكومه الاسرائيليه وعوده
الى سده الحكم من جديد وايضا فرد الموضوع
بكل قوه على طاوله المجلس الوزاري المصغر
ستبدا المفاوضات تجديه وتعيين منسق
اسرائيلي جديد والان لا يوجد منصق بين
لشؤون الاسرى والمفقودين وبهذا ربما قد
تعيد مصر همم مسيحيه الحميده في سبيل
اهتمام صفقه على اسس جديده على اسس ان يتم
على اسس انسانيه يتم بموجبها الافراج
عن الاطفال عن النساء وايضا عن المرضى بان
هذا هو المبدا الذي تسير بموجبه السياسه
شكرا
من القدس